te voy a hacer una pregunta y ya sabes
cuál es la norma no vale buscarla en
google ni tampoco recurrir a la
wikipedia que sabes acerca de armenia
que conoces de este remoto país ubicado
en plena región del cáucaso y ojo porque
armenia tiene cosas muy interesantes por
ejemplo fue el primer país cristiano de
toda la historia es una potencia en el
ajedrez e incluso tiene su propio
alfabeto
[Música]
pero amigos y armenia os resulta un país
desconocido esperando un momento porque
dentro de él hay no sé cómo decirlo otro
país la autoconstituida república de
arzak anteriormente conocida como
nagorno karabaj tal cual como lo
escucháis hablamos de una república
atentos que no es reconocida por ningún
país del mundo pero que proclamó su
independencia en 1991 y que tiene su
propio gobierno su propio parlamento su
constitución e incluso sus propias
fuerzas armadas
[Música]
vamos que es algún pasaporte con el que
poder viajar por el mundo lo tienen todo
eso sí a ver no es que los ciudadanos de
esta curiosa república estén aislados
todos ellos tienen el pasaporte armenio
porque esta especie de país es un
estrecho aliado de armenia
veréis durante la etapa soviética este
territorio fue uno blast una provincia
autónoma de la república socialista
soviética de azerbaiyán pero cuando la
unión soviética se vino abajo su
gobierno decidió que prefería formar
parte de armenia lo que dio lugar a una
larga guerra de más de 4 años que dejó a
sus espaldas decenas de miles de muertos
por cierto os habéis dado cuenta de la
enorme cantidad de conflictos que se
originan por un pedazo de tierra pero no
nos desviemos el caso amigos es que
armenia lo tiene todo absolutamente todo
para encandilar a cualquier adicto a la
política y por supuesto también para que
hablemos de este país aquí en visual
político un país dentro de otro una
reciente guerra en 2016 una enorme
diáspora una revolución democrática e
incluso un potencial quebradero de
cabeza para el mismísimo vladimir putin
atentos
[Aplausos]
sin salida al mar situado entre grandes
montañas y con algo menos de tres
millones de habitantes creo amigos que
podemos decir que armenia es un lugar
remoto
si tuviéramos que describir muy
brevemente este país tal vez podríamos
decir que es algo así como la típica
república soviética que siempre siempre
aparece en las películas de hollywood
eso sí sin el militar rebelde ni los
deseos de regresar al comunismo pero con
todos sus oligarcas y con la corrupción
por todas las esquinas y es que amigos
ahora sí hablando en serio lo cierto es
que este país tiene muchos pero que
muchos problemas
armenia logró su independencia en
septiembre de 1991 y hoy 27 años después
el desempleo supera el 20% uno de cada
tres ciudadanos vive en la pobreza la
deuda pública se ha multiplicado por
cuatro en la última década las
infraestructuras se desmoronan y además
tiene un serio problema con la
emigración
[Música]
[Aplausos]
si habéis escuchado bien con la
emigración fijaos
se calcula que en todo el mundo hay unos
12 millones de armenios pero sólo 3
millones viven en armenia hablamos por
tanto de una de las mayores diásporas de
todo el mundo sólo 1 de cada 5 armenios
viven en armenia
y no sólo eso cada año que pasa de media
cuarenta mil cuarenta mil armenios más
abandonan el país en muchos casos para
no volver salvo de vacaciones claro lo
peor de todo es que las cosas no parecen
estar mejorando fijaos por ejemplo en
cómo ha evolucionado la entrada de
inversión extranjera en los últimos años
pero llegados a este punto puede que te
estés preguntando y por qué diantres las
cosas van tan mal pues amigos una
explicación de por qué las cosas no
marchan nada pero que nada bien es la
corrupción y el enorme poder que tienen
los oligarcas cercanos al poder
[Música]
veréis durante los últimos 20 años el
partido republicano de armenia o un
partido teóricamente de centroderecha y
pro mercado pero realmente un club de
grandes oligarcas ha convertido la
política de este país en todo un
entramado de intereses y privilegios
desde hace dos décadas si quieres hacer
negocios en armenia afiliarse a este
partido es un paso casi obligatorio y si
eres extranjero dejarte caer por allí
tampoco es una mala idea sin embargo
espera un momento porque en abril de
2018 los armenios dijeron basta y que
pensáis que hicieron pues ni más ni
menos que montar toda una revolución en
la calle atentos
la revolución
[Música]
tras 10 años desastrosos en el poder y
tras agotar el número máximo de mandatos
el presidente césar se quiso copiar la
estrategia de putin y ser reelegido como
primer ministro
para ello sacó adelante una reforma que
básicamente traspasaba los principales
poderes del presidente al primer
ministro por cierto qué pensáis hablamos
de una buena jugada para mantener el
poder o simplemente de una burla a todos
los armenios pues amigos la gente de
este país lo tuvo muy pero que muy claro
el presidente se estaba riendo de todos
ellos vale que a mañana en las
elecciones que utilizaran el poder a su
antojo y que los grandes oligarcas
usaran el gobierno para hacerse de oro
pero esto ya era demasiado tras diez
años de una gestión peor que mala del
presidente ser era toda una burla y eso
los armenios no lo iban a consentir así
que dicho y hecho
no
por qué
[Música]
el día 13 de abril
nicole para xinjiang un periodista y
diputado de la oposición en el
parlamento armenio se puso al frente de
una movilización de protesta
al principio muy poca gente se sumó a
este movimiento de protesta pero en
cuestión de días la cosa cambió vaya que
si cambio el 16 de abril grandes grupos
de estudiantes se unieron a la protesta
y cuatro días más tarde el viernes 20 de
abril
el movimiento concentraba ya en ereván
la capital del país a decenas de miles
de personas
en ese momento fue cuando el gobierno
que hasta ahora se había tomado estas
movilizaciones como un pequeño incordio
comenzó a ponerse nervioso nervioso de
verdad y que penséis que hizo pues
detener a los principales cabecillas de
estas concentraciones completamente
pacíficas incluyendo a su líder al
mismísimo nicole para xinjiang al mismo
tiempo se anunció que la policía
dispersara por la fuerza sin
contemplaciones las concentraciones de
protestas
[Música]
vamos que parece que el movimiento
llegaba a su fin verdad pues amigos todo
lo contrario fue el punto de no retorno
a partir de ese momento más de 200 mil
200 mil personas en un país de menos de
3 millones de habitantes se echaron a la
calle la capital el país quedó
paralizado los centros de trabajo las
escuelas y las universidades cerraron
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y la policía ante semejante
concentración de gente decidió no hacer
absolutamente nada así que todo esto
animó a que cada vez más y más gente se
echaran a la calle de una forma
completamente pacífica y la verdad
bastante alegre
de repente amigos la ciudadanía se había
puesto en pie para decir basta la
revolución del terciopelo estaba en
marcha el resultado a las cuatro de la
tarde del lunes 23 de abril apenas diez
días después de que nicole pan xinjiang
pusiera en marcha el movimiento de
protesta shared sang xian anunciaba su
dimisión unas semanas más tarde el
propio para xinjiang el líder de las
protestas un periodista que en los
últimos años ha sufrido un intento de
atentado y ha sido encarcelado por
enfrentarse al gobierno ha sido ahora
nombrado primer ministro
y es que amigos cuando una sociedad se
pone en pie para exigir libertad
democracia y justicia resulta muy
difícil frenarla
el caso es que armenia tiene ahora una
oportunidad para cambiar de rumbo
enfrentarse a los oligarcas y terminar
con la corrupción generalizada que está
consumiendo el país quiero asegurar a
los que quieren invertir crear empleo
que han estado enviando dinero durante
años pero no han pensado nunca en crear
aquí un negocio que la hora de vuestro
regreso ha llegado este proceso debe
empezar inmediatamente
nicole mansilla nuevo primer ministro de
armenia claro que espera un momento
porque no va a ser tan fácil primero
porque el partido republicano sigue
controlando el congreso y sus
representantes ya han dicho que iban a
dimitir ni se lo van a poner fácil al
nuevo primer ministro y eso no es todo
por si fuera poco además de los
problemas internos armenia tiene otros
dos retos de peso uno de ellos la rusia
de vladimir putin
rusia y la amenaza acería
moscú tiene un control tan grande sobre
la economía en la defensa y la política
exterior de armenia que muchos analistas
hablan sin tapujos de una especie de
ocupación de facto sin ir más lejos en
la ciudad armenia de guiumri el ejército
ruso tiene ojo junto a la frontera turca
un importante base militar con más de
5000 soldados aviones mig-29 y sistemas
de misiles antiaéreos s-300
pero no sólo es una cuestión militar el
país también depende en gran medida de
las remesas que envían los más de 2
millones de armenios que viven en rusia
y además el gigante ruso es su primer
socio comercial y controla completamente
el suministro energético fijaos lo que
ocurre en armenia es algo antinatural
está al lado de irán un importante
exportador de gas pero importa su gas
desde siberia como resultado de acuerdos
que hacen poco más que legalizar la
ocupación de armenia de hecho según los
términos de dichos acuerdos
ereván no puede llegar a un acuerdo con
teherán a menos que moscú lo acepte
rubén vergara be an editor de 1 in punto
amén pues bien el caso es que hasta
ahora vladímir putin ha tenido muy
buenas relaciones con el gobierno y ya
sabéis todos que a putin este tipo de
revoluciones digamos que no le
entusiasman así que la advertencia está
sobre la mesa
cuidado con mirar demasiado o prestar
atención a las llamadas seductoras de la
unión europea o estados unidos pero
amigos aquí no termina todo
otra gran amenaza os acordáis de la red
pública de altza pues bien es una
especie de protectorado de armenia de
tal forma que azerbayán lo considera a
todas luces territorio ocupado y no
tiene reparos en manifestar su intención
de reconquistar este territorio
[Música]
de momento los enfrentamientos no son
extraños e incluso hacer relativamente
poco en 2016 se produjeron en este lugar
durante cuatro días duros
enfrentamientos hasta que putin exigió
el alto el fuego
pero evidentemente el riesgo existe
sobre todo porque azerbayán tiene
petróleo y gas y eso amigos supone
dinero para que os hagáis una idea el
presupuesto militar de azerbaiyán es tan
grande como el presupuesto del gobierno
de armenia así que si un día rusia
decidiera a lavarse las manos
armenia podría tener muchos pero que
muchos problemas en fin así están las
cosas pero ahora turno para ti conocidas
en la república de arsa déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta muchísimas gracias por
cierto por todo vuestro apoyo en patrón
está siendo increíble estamos preparando
muchas cositas que pronto empezará y
saber y que creemos nos van a gustar
pero como siempre si te ha gustado el
vídeo
dale like y no olvides suscribirte al
canal si aún no lo has hecho un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]